Senator Harry Reid is one of the worst
Liars ever to grace the national stage
he accused 2012 presidential candidate
Mitt Romney of cheating on his taxes
without any evidence then celebrated his
lies since it helped prevent Romney from
becoming president he called George W
Bush a liar who betrayed the country he
said paying taxes was voluntary which is
weird since it's not attacked the Koch
brothers his unamerican and admitted
he'd rather let a child with cancer
suffer than fund the government feet
piecemeal his Senate tenure was marked
by conflict and cram downs from the
Obamacare Fiasco to the destruction of
the filibuster both of which by the way
will now backfire on Democrats yet there
was Reid receiving accolades yesterday
for his supposedly grand tenure in the
Senate and there he was in the pages of
the New York Times lecturing Americans
about of all things the supposes scourge
of fake news the New York Times tweeted
quote much of the responsibility for
separating what's real and what's fake
will will fall on Democrats writes Harry
Reid here are some of Reid's other
sterling advice in the New York Times
close to Republicans I say recognize the
difference between campaigning and
governing and between knee-jerk
opposition's the accomplishments of the
Obama era really Reid spent his entire
career opposing Republican policy in
knee-jerk fashion and what
accomplishments in the Obama era are
worth upholding exactly Reid
specifically cites Obamacare he says
it's a dramatic miss reading of your
mandate to destroy it even though Obama
never had a clear mandate to pass
Obamacare and the public spent the next
six years destroying the Democrats from
us reading their mandate in passing that
monstrosity Reid wrote to Democrats I
say it has never been more important to
stand up for the things we believe in we
are entering a new Gilded Age nobody's
gotten richer off government than Reid
he spent his entire life in government
making about 190,000 bucks a year and
now he's worth somewhere between three
and ten million dollars the Clintons are
wealthy because of political
back-scratching too he wrote quote much
of the responsibility for separating
what is real and what is fake will fall
on Democrats again this is nuts
Reid is one of the worst liars in the
history of the Senate he also wrote
quote when Democrats picked their fights
next year they can do so knowing that
win or lose they will be debating in a
Senate that we made more open and more
transparent this is Reid defending the
idiotic move of nuking the filibuster on
cabinet picks its crippled his party
going into an era of Republican
leadership in the White House in
Congress Reid will significantly improve
America by leaving the Senate but
recounting his legacy well that should
remind Americans just why Democrats
should not be trusted with power
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show oh so much to get you today here on
the bench pho plus we're doing the
mailbag today we're broadcasting on
Friday obviously because we missed a
show earlier in the day but we will be
starting to do some Friday shows in the
near future we have some surprises
planned for that which is why I need to
subscribe it daily wire comm but first
before we get to today's show we have to
say hello to our advertisers over at
wink so this is the company that you go
to for wine so you don't know anything
about wine right you know you don't know
what wine to bring your friends house
was really expensive you don't know the
difference between a Cabernet and Merlot
you don't know any of this stuff but
what you do know is what you like in
terms of the food you like so you go
over to wink calm you go over to their
website it's wink calm and it's try wink
calm rather you go over to try wink calm
and when you go there they have this
little survey where it asks the kinds of
foods that you like what kind of food
combinations you like and then they pick
a wine for you from their stock they
produce the lines themselves the lines
are really really affordable the Alma
staff members have had their wine and
given the quality of the podcast you
would think they drink the wine all the
time but no they usually have it only in
their off hours but they they say that
the wine is really really good they even
had a wine party here that was that was
really spectacular apparently and they
say the products just great again if you
don't know anything about wine but you
want an affordable wine to bring over
your friend's house and make sure that
you don't look like a fool wink is the
place to go it's try winked calm / been
try winked calm / spend you get 20 bucks
off right now when you go to try winked
calm / Bend they even cover the shipping
it's personalized against your palate
and the line is apparently really really
good all of my staffers swear by it
which means that either the wines good
or they're all alcoholics alrighty so
today we begin with the fact the
Democrats have really given up the only
tool they ever had for being able to
hold Republicans in check and and number
one they're their biggest tool for
holding Republicans in check for a long
time was the media they believed the
media would be able to stop Republicans
from being terrible and vindictive and
Republican and now they've blown all
credibility and you can see how badly
they've blown their credibility over
this whole thing they've been discussing
about fake news fake news this big news
that for those who have missed this
controversy Democrats
saying now since the election that the
reason Donald Trump was is because
people believed fake News Now Democrats
haven't really distinguished between
headlines that are just flat-out not
true and messages that they don't like
so when Donald Trump says things like
radical Islam is something Democrats
never say and it's a threat then a lot
of people will say that's fake news
that's heard Democrats say the word
radical Islam right the overall message
is true and he was making an
overstatement but obviously he didn't
mean for it to be taken literally fake
news is like pizza gay pizza gate is
fake news because there's no evidence
that pizza gate is real that there's
this this sex slavery ring being run out
of this this pizzeria in middle of
Washington DC but the Democrats don't
bother to make that distinction and they
never have in fact they've probably
they've actually promulgated fake news
and a routine rate as so long as it
helps them so that's actually destroyed
their capacity to be fact checkers
nobody trusts you to check the facts if
you're the person who promulgated half
the false stories in the first place the
same people who complain about fake news
are the people who are spending
literally months talking about hands up
don't you write there's that famous
picture from CNN of all of their anchors
doing hands up don't shoot and those
people on CNN and those same exact
people are now complaining about the
scourge of fake news that drove Trump to
the presidency well at a certain point
we stopped listening to them and that
was real good for Donald Trump both
because it meant that we didn't listen
to them when they slandered him and it
also meant that we didn't listen to them
when they told the truth about him which
worked out really well for Donald Trump
it means that we're all gonna have to
find new sources of information people
that you trust to bring you the news my
general rule of thumb is I mean aside
from the basic rules like everything has
to be double sourced my general rules of
thumb on news to trust news outlets to
trust is do they ever print stories that
are not in their own economic
self-interest
do they ever print stories that don't
that run counter to their own narrative
do they ever print stories that debunk
things that you know that they believe
and that's usually a pretty good
indicator so I think the Washington Post
is better than the New York Times
the New York Times have rarely run
stories that run counter to kind of
their leftist narrative the Washington
Post actually does sometimes and and so
I think it's a better outlet again
that's a quick and dirty rule of thumb
you know Breitbart is never gonna run
anything that's counter to their
interests Infowars doesn't run stuff
that's counter to their interests and
that's why those sites are less
trustworthy and the same thing holds
true on the Left I don't trust
Huffington
because everything they run is is in the
interest of their narrative one of the
things we try to do a daily wear and
this is not you know a this is not
patting ourselves on the back although
it is is is that we try to have a
variety of perspectives so John Nolte
who's one of our editors at large he and
I disagree on virtually everything with
what I did on all Trump we try to make
room for that because we want opposing
voice voices to be presented any case
the mainstream media haven't done this
and so they blew all their credibility
and here is a perfect example of how
they blew all of their credibility
here's Brian Williams who faked his own
life story multiple times right he was
in a helicopter in Iraq he was almost
shot down he was watching bodies float
by him during Hurricane Katrina he was
present at the storming of the beaches
at Normandy he was actually on the
original mission - mission to the moon
and now he's still on MSNBC right they
brought him back on MSNBC after he was
ousted from NBC Nightly News and here he
is - crying fake news as we talked about
here last night fake news played a role
in this election and continues to find a
wide audience a BuzzFeed news study of
Donald Trump's own tweets where they
follow back news stories to their root
source found more of them came from
Breitbart originally than from any other
single source and of course he's ripping
on Breitbart his fake news now as a
former employee of Breitbart I can say
that not everything that Breitbart
prints is faking is the vast majority of
what Breitbart does is agregate they
actually just rewrite other people's
stories a lot but again Brian Williams
complaining about fake news is rather
ironic and what he doesn't know there is
look at some of the other sources that
the Trump was tweeting during the
campaign right some of the other big
sources the Washington Post right Fox
news.com the hill
the New York Post Daily Mail right he
even tweeted the Huffington Post a few
times right so the idea that a National
Review which really didn't like him very
much the idea that all of the people who
are tweeting were only tweeting from
Breitbart obviously that's the biggest
circle there and yes I think Breitbart
was a trump Pravda outlet but that
doesn't mean that every headline that
came from Breitbart is fake news nor
does it mean the entire outlet can
simply be thrown out with the bathwater
we actually have to evaluate each story
and there are certain reporters at
Breitbart who are really quite good I
think the Charlie Spearing is a good
reporter over at Breitbart I think Aaron
Klein / Brent
Jerusalem is a very good reporter I
think Matt Boyle is not a very good
reporter but I think there plenty of
good reporters at Breitbart even though
it's an outlet that I think is overall
just a shilling shilling for Trump but
again the left blew all of its
credibility here and so when they call
when they call foul here when they
scream about about fake news
it just doesn't resonate I mean Hillary
Clinton is doing the same routine now
instead of just recognizing you guys
lost the election because you ran a bad
candidate and she ran an abysmal
campaign and he didn't understand what a
lot of Americans were complaining about
instead you were too busy cutting videos
with you know with mary j blige in which
she's singing to you questions instead
of just recognizing that they're trying
to blame some outside source cheating
whether it's the Russians cheating or
whether it is whether it's fake news
here's Hillary Clinton's a crying fake
news the epidemic of malicious fake news
and false propaganda that flooded social
media over the past year it's now clear
that so-called fake news can have
real-world consequences this isn't about
politics or partisanship lives are at
risk lives of ordinary people just
trying to go about their days to do
their jobs contribute to their
communities
it's a danger be addressed and address
quickly bipartisan legislation is making
its way through Congress to boost the
government's response to foreign
propaganda and Silicon Valley is
starting to grapple with the challenge
and threat of fake news whose gonna
determine what's fake news and what's
not fake news that's really the biggest
question now some stuff yeah I do want
to avoid the tendency to say nothing is
fake news because the media / label
things fake news there are things that
are fake news there are things that are
fake news here she's saying pizza gate
is fake news and that's what drove this
guy over to this pizzeria to try and
shoot up the problem is the problem is
that if you are going to if you are
going to you know label everything fake
news from pizza gate to to Benghazi
right and remember how the media
downplayed Benghazi they said there was
nothing to see there there certainly was
something to see there you know the the
fact that they they conflated all of
that destroyed their own credibility and
so when Hillary Clinton is standing
there decrying fake news it's like wait
a second why you don't get to do
this maya mika brzezinski who's another
one of these these you know kind of
dicey reporters over on MSNBC she's out
morning joe she's she says you know
hillary can complain about fake news
hillary complains about fake news and
then mica this morning she says you know
hillary tried to get me thrown off air
for simply saying that this was a
competitive race i was concerned the
campaign was not understanding that
perhaps there was an arrogance that
needed to get up there i worse and
understand that this isn't over
i'll just say it NBC got a call from the
campaign like I had had done something
that was journalistically inappropriate
or something and needed to be pulled off
the air I mean think about that no
that's just that's injure okay and you
know the fact that Hillary Clinton is
saying fake news this fake news that and
then she tried to have a reporter pulled
off the arrow supposedly because that
reporter was was saying that this was a
more competitive race it just
demonstrates how silly all of this is
hill again Hillary Clinton has no
credibility to call out fake news
because Hillary Clinton is the
propagator of fake news I mean you
remember that Hillary Clinton once
claimed that her husband's all of the
all of these circumstances surrounding
her husband and Lewinsky all of it was
lies it was all just vast right-wing
propaganda the great story here for
anybody willing to find it and write
about it and explain it is this vast
right-wing conspiracy that has been
conspiring against my husband since the
day he announced for president okay and
so she's been singing the same tune for
30 years Democrats always sing the same
team and they lose it must be that
somebody lied about us it can't be that
somebody told the truth about us the
truth is virtually all of the anti
Hillary stories were true virtually all
the anti Trump stories were true
virtually none of the pro Trump or pro
Hillary stories were true that was sort
of the theme of the campaign as we were
pointing it out plus again in Hillary
Clinton I say she's the purveyor of lies
I mean here's just a few of her whoppers
and this was you find these these lies
on on YouTube they are going to people
showing videos of Donald Trump insulting
Islam and Muslims in order to recruit
more radical jihadists if fact checkers
have said that she was wrong there is no
video that Isis is using when she
thought there's a pattern now of her
claiming that videos exist that do not
exist I remember landing under sniper
fire there was supposed to be some kind
of a greeting ceremony at the airport
but instead we just ran with our heads
down to get into the vehicles to get to
our base her arrival in Bosnia was not
quite as dramatic as Clinton put it
memory should always match the videotape
and family members of the Benghazi
victims are saying you lied to them in
that hearing we've seen rage and
violence directed at American embassies
over an aweful internet video that we
had nothing to do with she told me
something entirely different ethic
casket ceremony she said it was the
cause of the the the video and that she
would get back to me okay so that's just
an example of some of the lies that
Hillary Clinton was telling in their
shoes decrying fake news and talking
about how terrible it is very difficult
to take the Democrats seriously and the
media seriously when they've blown their
own credibility which means the Trump
basically has free reign he basically
has run of the place he has run of the
place and that's either a good thing or
that's a bad thing and we'll talk about
that I have to go over to daily water to
subscribe because we're gonna talk about
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing
and and what comes next here daily
Wired's I come and subscribe $8 a month
and if you want an annual subscription
that that will run you still $8 a month
but you get a but you get you get a copy
of my of my new novel true allegiance
autograph I'm gonna go sign a bunch in
the other room and and you can be part
of the unit part of our podcast team the
mailbag is coming up today get to be
part of the mailbag we'll do some live
mailbag today which means we'll take
your questions live on air which is
pretty exciting we have plenty of
goodies coming in Shapiro store is
coming lots of we're gonna be rolling
out lots of product in the new year and
you get significant discounts on all of
that by becoming subscriber over at
Daley wire.com
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the United States
[Music]
you